نحن الان في معبر اشكيت الواقع اخصى شمال
السودان على الحدود المصريه السودانيه هذا
المعبر منذ اكثر من اسبوع وحركه دؤوبه تدب
فيه منذ قيام الكثير من السودانيين
بالعبور من هذه المنطقه نحو مصر
حركه الفارين من المعارك المستمره في
الخرطوم لا تتوقف هذا المعبر يبعد حوالي
الف كيلو متر من العاصمه الخرطوم
والكثيرين يفضلون هذا المعبر لتوفر
التسهيلات اللوجستيه والاداريه حيث تتواجد
في مدينه وادي حلفا الكثير من التسهيلات
هناك القنصليه المصريه التي تمنح
التاشيرات للمغادرين وايضا مقر للجوازات
السودانيه والذي يقدم الكثير من التسهيلات
سواء للجوازات السودانيه الذين يريدون
اضافات لابنائهم لتجديدات الجواز وبالتالي
هذا المعبر هو الاكثر كثافه مقارنه بم
كل المعابر اتقفلت حقيقه بالحرب اللي ما
عندنا فيها اي يدي وانا تحركت تقريبا لحد
ما وصلت هنا ممكن يكون ليه زي تمانيه ايام
ايوه اللي هي بمراحل مياه الخرطوم كل
الكبائر مقفله طبعا الكبر الوحيده اللي
كانت شغال عليها كوبري الصعبه الحلفايه
المعبر الوحيد القاله كويس اللي هو المعبر
بتاع حلفا ده يعني سمعنا عبر الاخرى
الكلام حول مزدحمه جدا جدا والكثير من
السودانيين الكثير ايضا من الرعايه
الاجانب الذين يحاورون العبور طبعا مراحل
كثيره وبدا من الخرطوم والولايات ثم
الوصول لهذا المعبر الذي كما ترون يشهدوا
ازدحاما كثيرا من الجنسيات مختلفه
وبالتالي
الانتظار يطول هنا هنا الكثير من الباصات
تقريبا الباص الواحد يحمل قرابه 100 شخص
هناك الكثير من الرصاد لا زالت متوقفه
تنتظر دورها هذا المعبر القدره
الاستيعابيه لحجم العابرين قد لا يتوافق
مع كميه
المسافرين القديم بمقاعاتهم بالمعابر
الاخرى التي لا تتوفر فيها على الخدمات
حسن رزاق الجزيره من معبر اشكيت على
الحدود السودانيه المصريه
[موسيقى]